this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix sleep and
their mattresses which i've been using
since 2017. i have two of them upstairs
from where i'm sitting at this moment
helix has gone beyond the bedroom and
started making sofas they launched a
company called all form
a-l-l-f-o-r-m and they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores so i'm
sitting in my living room right now and
it's entirely all form furniture i've
got two chairs i've got an ottoman and i
have an l sectional couch and i'll come
back to that you can pick your fabric
they're all spill stain and scratch
resistant the sofa color the color of
the legs the sofa size the shape to make
sure it's perfect for you and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular and easy these things fit
together kind of like lego pieces
they've got arm chairs love seats all
the way up to an eight seat sectional so
there's something for everyone you can
also start small and kind of build on
top of it if you want to get a smaller
couch and then build out on it which is
actually in a way what i did because i
can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman in a matter of about 60 seconds
it's pretty rad so i mentioned i have
all these different things in this room
i use the natural leg finish which is
their lightest color and i dig it i mean
i've been using these things hours and
hours and hours every single day so
i am using what i am sharing with you
guys and if getting a sofa without
trying it in store sounds risky you
don't need to worry all form sofas are
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it that's
more than three months and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a full refund your sofa frame
also has a forever warranty that's
literally forever so check it out take a
look they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked much better
than i could have imagined and i'm very
very happy so to find your perfect sofa
check out allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m.com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout that's allforum.com
tim and use code tim at checkout
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement i've been asked this for
years the answer is invariably ag-1 by
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance so you can cover
your bases if you're traveling if you're
just busy if you're not sure if your
meals or where they should be it covers
your bases i've recommended it
since the four hour body which was god
eons ago 2010 and i did not get paid to
do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole food source
ingredients you'll be hard-pressed to
find a more nutrient-dense formula on
the market it has a multivitamin
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes and
adaptogens
you get the idea it is very very
comprehensive and i do my best of course
to focus on nutrient dense proper meals
but sometimes you're busy sometimes
you're traveling sometimes you just want
to make sure
that you are getting what you need ag-1
makes it easy to get a lot of nutrition
when whole foods aren't readily
available it's also nsf certified for
sport making it safe for competitive
athletes as what's on the label is in
the powder it's the ultimate all-in-one
nutritional supplement bundle in one
easy scoop right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show where it
is usually my job to deconstruct
world-class performers to tease out
their routines habits etc that you can
apply to your own life and lives this
episode is something different it's an
experimental format that i am super
excited about and apparently so are many
of you it's back by popular demand this
is an episode that scratches an itch
i've had for many years now i'm not
always able to listen to every great
podcast episode out there even when they
are by some of my closest friends to
answer that predicament i decided to ask
them many of my friends to send a top
segment from their own podcast
podcasts that i could listen to and more
importantly also share with you my dear
listeners my team edited them together
and here we are this episode is a
compilation of roughly 15 to 30 minute
clips from some of the best podcasters
and also best interviewees in the world
and certainly some of my favorites at
the beginning of each clip you will hear
an intro from the host and where to find
their work and podcast at the end i'll
also share one or two of my favorite
clips from episodes of the tim ferriss
show you can view this episode as a
buffet and i strongly suggest that you
check out the shows included if you like
my podcast you will very likely enjoy
the featured shows in this episode
for the full list of the guests featured
today see the episode's description or
as usual head to tim.blog podcast for
all the details and before you go
do you like this format please let me
know on twitter at t ferris
t-f-e-r-r-i-s-s and also
mention
cc at team tim ferriss if you remember
without further ado please enjoy
i'm andrew huberman and i'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology at
stanford school of medicine so i run a
research laboratory and i teach at
stanford but i'm also the host of the
hubermann lab podcast which is a weekly
podcast focused on science and
science-based tools for everyday life
the clip you're about to hear is from
our episode of the huberman lab podcast
entitled controlling your dopamine for
motivation focus and satisfaction
this episode on dopamine turned out to
be one of our more popular episodes and
the clip you're about to hear focuses on
this incredible molecule dopamine which
exists in all of us and in fact is the
universal chemical substrate by which
motivation focus and drive come to be
and it's an incredible molecule because
it doesn't care whether or not you're
pursuing work or a romantic partner or
some other sort of behavior or goal
it is simply a molecule that activates
specific neural circuits brain areas in
your body and head that drive you to
pursue more in fact others have referred
to dopamine as the molecule of more
those are not my words those are the
words of others i should point out so
contrary to popular belief dopamine
doesn't control happiness it controls
motivation and desire and craving that
is it controls the desire for more and
it has this incredible ability to put us
into action it shapes the way that we
think it shapes the way that we feel
about what we are doing
and it's very powerful and it has
various aspects to that power including
our dopamine baseline which you'll soon
learn about and peaks in dopamine that
ride on top of that baseline and make us
feel either more motivated or less
motivated over various periods of time
so here in the clip that follows you can
learn all about the biology of dopamine
in particular how to leverage the
biology of dopamine for motivation focus
and drive not just in the moment but
continually over and over across time if
you'd like to learn more about science
and science related tools for mental
health physical health and performance
you can find all episodes of the
huberman lab podcast at hubermanlab.com
it's there with links to all formats so
youtube apple spotify and other formats
of the podcast all those episodes are
also time stamped we were very inspired
and remain inspired by the tim ferriss
podcast and the incredibly detailed
timestamps that are there that allow
people to navigate to the specific
topics of interest easily so we have
time stamped all our podcasts in homage
to tim and of course we have great
respect for tim and one of the great
pioneers of modern podcasting and
sharing important information you can
also find huberman lab on instagram and
twitter and there we cover science and
science related tools some of which
overlap with information covered on the
human lab podcast and some of which is
distinct from information on the
huberman lab podcast and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in science
now i've been alluding to this dopamine
peaks versus dopamine baseline thing
since the beginning of the episode
talked about tonic and phasic release
and so forth but now let's really drill
into what this means and how to leverage
it
for our own purposes
in order to do that let's take a step
back and ask why would we have a
dopamine system like this why would we
have a dopamine system at all well we
have to remember
what our species primary interest is
our species like all species
has a main interest and that's to make
more of itself it's not just about sex
and reproduction it's about foraging for
resources
resources can be food it can be water it
can be salt it can be shelter it can be
social connection
dopamine is the universal currency of
foraging and seeking right we call
sometimes talk about motivation and
craving but what we mean in the
evolutionary adaptive context what we
mean is foraging and seeking seeking
water seeking food seeking mates
seeking things that make us feel good
and avoiding things that don't make us
feel good but in particular seeking
things that will provide sustenance and
pleasure in the short term and will
extend the species in the long term
once we understand that dopamine is a
driver for us to seek things
it makes perfect sense as to why it
would have a baseline level and it would
have peaks and that the baseline and
peaks would be related in some sort of
direct way here's what i mean by that
let's say that you were not alive now
but you were alive 10 000 years ago
and you woke up and you looked and you
realized you had minimal water
and you had minimal food left
maybe you have a child maybe you have a
partner maybe you're in an entire
village but you realize that you need
some you need things okay
you need to be able to generate the
energy to go seek those things and
chances are there were dangers in
seeking those things yes it could be
saber tooth tigers and things of that
sort but there are other dangers too
there's the danger of a cut to your skin
that could lead to infection there's the
danger of storms there's the danger of
cold there's the danger of leaving your
loved ones behind
so you go out in forage
right you could be hunting you could be
gathering or you could be doing both
the going out and foraging process
was we are certain driven by dopamine i
mean there's no fossil record of the
brain but these circuits have existed we
know for tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of years and they
are present in every animal not just
mammals but even in little worms like c
elegans the same process it's mediated
by dopamine
so dopamine drives you to go out and
look for things and then let's say you
find a couple berries these ones are
rotten these ones are good maybe you
hunt an animal and kill it or you find
an animal that was recently killed and
you decide to take the meat
you are going to achieve
or i should say experience some sort of
dopamine release you found the reward
that's great but then it needs to return
to some lower level why well because if
you just stayed there
you would never continue to forage for
more
it doesn't
just increase your baseline and then
stay there it goes back down and what's
very important to understand is that it
doesn't just go back down to the level
it was before
it goes down to a level below
what it was before you went out seeking
that thing now this is counter-intuitive
we often think oh okay i'm going to
pursue the win all right let's let's
move this to modern day i'm going to i'm
going to run this marathon i'm going to
train for this marathon then you run the
marathon and you finish you cross the
finish line you feel great and you would
think okay now i'm set for the entire
year i'm going to feel so much better
i'm going to feel this accomplishment in
my body it's going to be so great that's
not what happens
you might feel some of those things but
your level of dopamine has actually
dropped below baseline
now eventually it will ratchet back up
but two things are really important
first of all the extent to which it
drops below baseline is proportional to
how high the peak was so if you cross
the finish line
pretty happy it won't drop that much
below baseline afterward if you cross
the finish line ecstatic
well a day or two later you're going to
feel quite a bit lower than you would
otherwise you might not be depressed
because it depends on where that
baseline was to begin with but the
so-called postpartum depression that
people experience after giving birth
or after some big win a graduation
or any kind of celebration that
postpartum drop in mood and affect and
motivation is the drop in baseline
dopamine
this is very important to understand
because this happens on very rapid time
scales and it can last quite a long time
it also explains
the behavior that most of us are
familiar with of engaging in something
that we really enjoy going to a
restaurant that we absolutely love
or engaging in some way with some person
that we really really enjoy
but if we continue to engage in that
behavior over and over again
it kind of loses its edge
it starts to kind of
feel less exciting to us
some of us
experience that drop in excitement more
quickly and more severely than others
but everyone experiences that to some
extent
and this has
direct roots
in these evolutionarily conserved
circuits
some of you may be hearing this and
think no no no that's not how it works
for me i'm just riding higher and higher
all the time i love my kids i love my
job i love school i love wins i i don't
want losses i agree
we all feel good when we are achieving
things but oftentimes
we are feeling good because we are
layering in different
aspects of life consuming things and
doing things that increase our dopamine
we're getting those peaks
but
afterward the drop in baseline occurs
and it always takes a little while to
get back to our
stable baseline we really all have a
sort of dopamine set point and if we
continue to indulge in the same
behaviors or even different behaviors
that increase our dopamine in these big
peaks over and over and over again
we won't experience the same level of
joy from those behaviors
or from anything at all now that has a
name it's called addiction but even for
people who aren't addicted
even for people don't have an attachment
to any specific substance or behavior
this drop in below baseline after any
peak and dopamine
is substantial
and it governs whether or not we are
going to feel motivated to continue to
pursue other things
fortunately there's a way to work with
this such that we can constantly stay
motivated but also keep that baseline of
dopamine at an appropriate healthy level
now i'd like to talk about the positive
aspects of rewards for our behavior and
the negative aspects of rewards for our
behavior and from that
i will suggest a protocol by which you
can achieve a better relationship to
your activities and to your dopamine
system in fact it will help tune up your
dopamine system for discipline
hard work and motivation
hard work is hard
generally most people don't like working
hard
some people do but most people work hard
in order to achieve some end goal
end goals are terrific and rewards are
terrific whether or not they are
monetary social
or any kind
however
because of the way that dopamine relates
to our perception of time
working hard at something for sake of a
reward that comes afterward
can make the hard work much more
challenging and make us much less likely
to lean into hard work in the future let
me give you a couple examples by way of
data and experiments there's a classic
experiment done
actually at stanford many years ago
in which
children
in nursery school and kindergarten
drew pictures and they drew pictures
because they liked to draw
the researchers took kids that liked to
draw
and they started giving them a reward
for drawing the reward generally was a
gold star or some thing that a young
child would find rewarding
then they stopped giving them the gold
star
and what they found is the children had
a much lower tendency
to draw on their own no reward now
remember this was an activity that prior
to receiving a reward the children
intrinsically enjoyed and selected to do
no one was telling them to draw
what this relates to is so-called
intrinsic versus extrinsic reinforcement
when we receive rewards even if we give
ourselves rewards for something
we tend to associate less pleasure with
the actual activity itself that evoked
the reward now that might seem
counterintuitive but that's just way the
way that these dopaminergic circuits
work
and now understanding these peaks and
baselines and dopamine which i won't
review again
this should make sense
if you get a peak in dopamine from a
reward it's going to lower your baseline
and
the cognitive interpretation
is that you didn't really do the
activity because you enjoyed the
activity you did it for the reward now
this doesn't mean all rewards of all
kinds are bad
but
it's also important to understand that
dopamine controls our perception of time
when and how much dopamine we experience
is the way that we carve up what we call
our experience of time when we engage in
an activity let's say school or hard
work of any kind or exercise
because of the reward we are going to
give ourselves or receive at the end the
trophy the sunday
the meal
whatever it happens to be
we actually are extending the time bin
over which we are
analyzing or perceiving that experience
and because the reward comes at the end
we start to dissociate the neural
circuits for dopamine and reward that
would have normally been active during
the activity
and
because it all arrives at the end over
time we have the experience of less and
less pleasure from that particular
activity while we're doing it
now this is the antithesis of growth
mindset my colleague at stanford carol
dweck as many of you know has come up
with this incredible
theory and principle and actually goes
beyond theory and principle called
growth mindset which is this striving to
be better to be in this mindset of i'm
not there yet but striving itself is
the end goal and that of course delivers
you to tremendous performance has been
observed over and over and over again
that people that have growth mindset
kids that have growth mindset end up
performing very well because they're
focused on the effort itself and
all of us can cultivate growth mindset
the neural mechanism of cultivating
growth mindset involves learning to
access the rewards from effort and doing
and that's hard to do
because you have to engage this
prefrontal component of the mesolimbic
circuit you have to tell yourself okay
this effort is great this effort is
pleasurable even though you might
actually be in a state of physical pain
from the exercise or i can recall this
from college just feeling like i wanted
to get up from my desk but forcing
myself to study forcing myself and
forcing myself what you find over time
is that you can start to associate a
dopamine release you can evoke dopamine
release from
the friction and the challenge that you
happen to be in
you completely eliminate the ability to
generate
those circuits and the rewarding process
of being able to reward friction while
in effort
if you are focused only on the goal that
comes at the end because of the way that
dopamine marks time so if you say oh i'm
going to do this very hard thing
and i'm going to push and push and push
and push for that end goal that comes
later
not only
do you enjoy the process of what you're
doing less you actually make it more
painful while you're engaging in it you
make yourself less efficient at it
because if you were able to access
dopamine while in effort dopamine has
all these incredible properties of
increasing the amount of energy in our
body and in our mind our ability to
focus by way of dopamine's conversion
into epinephrine but also
you are undermining your ability to lean
back into that activity the next time
the next time you need
twice as much coffee and three times as
much loud music and four times as much
energy drink and the social connection
just to get out the door in order to do
the run or to study
so
what's
more beneficial in fact can serve as a
tremendous amplifier on all endeavors
that you engage in
especially hard endeavors is to a not
start layering in other sources of
dopamine in order to get to the starting
line not layering in other sources of
dopamine in order to be able to continue
but rather
to subjectively start to attach the
feeling of friction and effort
to an internally generated reward system
and this is
not meant to be vague this is a system
that exists in your mind that exists in
the minds of humans for hundreds of
thousands of years by which
you're not just pursuing the things that
are innately pleasurable food sex warmth
water when you're thirsty
but the beauty of this mesolimbic reward
pathway that i talked about earlier is
that it includes the forebrain so you
can tell yourself
the effort part is the good part i know
it's painful i know this doesn't feel
good but i'm focused on this i'm going
to start to access the reward you will
find the rewards meaning the dopamine
release inside of effort if you repeat
this over and over again and what's
beautiful about it is that it starts to
become reflexive for all types of effort
when we focus only on the trophy only on
the grade only on the win
as the reward you undermine that entire
process
so how do you do this
you do this
in those moments of the most intense
friction you tell yourself
this is very painful
and because it's painful
it will evoke an increase in dopamine
release later
meaning it will increase my baseline and
dopamine
but you also have to tell yourself that
in that moment
you are doing it by choice and you're
doing it because
you love it and i know that sounds like
lying to yourself and in some ways it is
lying to yourself but it's lying to
yourself in the context of a truth which
is
that you want it to feel better you want
it to feel even pleasurable now this is
very far and away different
from
thinking about the reward that comes at
the end the hot fudge sunday for after
you cross the finish line and you can
replace hot fudge sundae with whatever
reward happens to to be appealing to you
we revere people who are capable of
doing what i'm describing
david goggins comes to mind as a really
good example many of you are probably
familiar with david goggins former navy
seal who essentially has made a
post-military career career out of
explaining and sharing his process of
turning the effort into the reward
there are many other examples of this
too of course
throughout evolutionary history there's
no question that we revered people who
were willing to go out and forage and
hunt and gather and caretake
in ways that
other members of our species probably
found exhausting and probably would have
preferred to just put their feet up or
soak them in a cool stream rather than
continue to forage
the ability to access this pleasure from
effort
aspect of our dopaminergic circuitry
is without question the most powerful
aspect of dopamine in our biology of
dopamine and the beautiful thing is it's
accessible to all of us but just to
highlight the things that can interfere
with and prevent
you from getting dopamine release
from effort itself
don't spike dopamine prior to engaging
in effort
and don't spike dopamine after engaging
in effort learn to spike your dopamine
from effort itself
welcome i'm your host greg mcewen and
for those who are new here i'm the
author of two new york times bestsellers
effortless and essentialism and the host
of this newly minted greg mcewen podcast
where i am on a journey with you
to learn how to negotiate what really
matters when it really matters with the
people who really matter
and this really dovetails with the core
idea within essentialism itself
essentialism isn't about getting more
done in less time it's about getting
only the right things done
have you ever found yourself stretched
too thin
have you ever been busy but not
productive do you feel like your time is
constantly hijacked by other people's
agenda for you
if you aren't suggest any of these the
way out is the way of the essentialist
so by the end of this episode you will
be better able to eliminate the
non-essentials from your life today i'm
going to share with you five specific
things you can do right now actionable
advice for how you can be more of an
essentialist by the end of this episode
you will be better able to eliminate
the non-essentials from your life so
let's get to it
[Music]
[Music]
if you want to accelerate your
understanding of what i share with you
today here's how to do it teach the
ideas in this podcast to someone else
within the next 24 to 48 hours of
listening
it will deepen your understanding it
will help you to implement the ideas
faster yourself
and it will also help educate the people
around you so that you're not the lone
essentialist in the room
on a bright winter day i visited my wife
anna in the hospital even in the
hospital anna was radiant
but i also knew she was exhausted
it was the day after our precious
daughter was born healthy and happy at
seven pounds three ounces
yet what should have been one of the
happiest most serene days of my life was
actually filled with tension
even as my beautiful new baby lay in my
wife's tired arms i was on the phone and
on email
and i was feeling pressured to go to a
client meeting
my colleague had written days before
friday between one and two would be a
bad time to have a baby because i need
you to be at this client meeting
it was now friday and though i was
pretty certain
that the email had been written in jest
i felt pressure to attend instinctively
i knew what to do it was clearly a time
to be there for my wife and newborn
child so when i asked whether i planned
to attend the meeting i said with all
the conviction i could muster
yes
so to my shame while my wife lay in the
hospital with our hours-old baby
i went to the meeting what was i doing
there i had said yes to please
and in doing so i'd hurt my family my
integrity and even the client
relationship
as it turned out exactly nothing came
from that meeting but even if it had
surely i had made a fool's bargain
in trying to keep everyone happy i had
sacrificed what matters most
on reflection i discovered this
important lesson if you don't prioritize
your life
someone else will
the word priority came into the english
language in the 1400s it was singular
priority the very first or priorest
thing
and according to peter drucker it stayed
singular for the next 500 years so it
wasn't until the industrial revolution
where people started using the term
priorities pluralizing the term and yet
what does that even mean how can you
have very very many very first before
all other things things and yet haven't
you been to a meeting yourself where
somebody said with no sense of irony at
all here are my 34 priorities
so one way back one thing you can do now
is to identify what the priority is in
this moment
this first practice i will simply call
win because it's a nice acronym what's
important now
that's how to begin this journey to
becoming an essentialist don't overthink
it
but ask the question
what's important now
so number one was win and number two is
less
many intelligent ambitious people
struggled to figure out what is
the priority for them in this moment and
for a perfectly good reason a reason i
call the paradox of success
it can be summed up in four predictable
phases phase one
when we really have clarity of purpose
it enables us to succeed at our endeavor
phase two
when we have success we gain a
reputation as a go-to person we become
good also and so who is always there
when you need him
we are presented with increased options
and opportunities phase three
when we have increased options and
opportunities which is actually code for
demands upon our time and energies it
leads to diffused efforts we get spread
thinner and thinner which leads to phase
four we become distracted from what
would otherwise be our highest level of
contribution the effect of our success
has been to undermine the very clarity
that led to success in the first place
overstating the point in order to make
it
the pursuit of success can be a catalyst
for failure especially if it leads to
what jim corns has called the
undisciplined pursuit of more and the
antidote to that is the disciplined
pursuit
of less
what i would encourage you to do right
now is to start a
said no to list
that is in addition to your to-do list
write down the things that you've
actually said no to
this will have a couple of benefits to
you first it will be empowering to
discover you can say no many of us are
novices at the idea we just don't even
say the word we don't use it
we could but we don't
the second is as your list accumulates
you'll be able to evaluate whether
you're pleased with that decision
because i'm not advocating you start
saying no to everyone and everything
without really thinking about it that
would be a different sort of book a book
called noism or something but the idea
of essentialism is to say yes to the
essentials but also no to the
non-essentials so that you can reinvest
that time resource
your attention
your energy to the things that really
are
most important number three is trade-off
imagine you could go back to 1972 and
invest a dollar in each company in the s
p 500
which company would provide you the
largest return on your investment by 30
years later like 2002 would it be ge ibm
intel mcdonald's berkshire hathaway the
correct answer and almost nobody ever
gets the answer right
is southwest airlines it's a pretty
startling answer because
the airline industry is notoriously bad
at generating profits yet southwest led
by herb kelleher
has consistently year after year
produced amazing financial results
did they do it by trying to be all
things to all people
or did they do it through a disciplined
pursuit of less
rather than fly to every destination
they deliberately chose to offer only
point-to-point flights instead of
jacking up prices to cover the cost of
meals
they decided they would serve none
instead of assigning seats in advance
they would let people choose them as
they got on the plane
instead of upselling their passengers on
glitzy first class service they offered
only coach these trade-offs weren't made
by default but by design
and each and every one of them was made
as part of a deliberate strategy to keep
costs down did they run the risk of
alienating customers who wanted the
broader range of destinations yes
but kelleher and his executive team were
totally clear about what the company was
a low-cost airline and what they were
not and their trade-offs reflected as
much
kelleher explained it this way he said
you have to look at every opportunity
and say well no
i'm sorry we're not going to do a
thousand different things that really
won't contribute much to the end results
we are trying to achieve
at first southwest was lambasted by
critics naysayers everybody yet after
years it became clear that southwest was
onto something and competitors in the
industry took notice of southwest's
soaring profits and started trying to
imitate their approach
but instead of adopting kelleher's
essentialist approach carte blanche they
instead chose a straddled strategy
in the simplest term straddling means
keeping your existing strategy intact
while simultaneously also trying to
adopt the strategy of a competitor and
one of the most visible attempts of that
at the time was continental airlines
they started a program called
continental light and in the end it
confused everybody involved so much that
they set records in the airline industry
for complaints per day
they lost 150 million dollars and they
fired the ceo the moral of the story is
ignoring the reality of trade-offs is a
terrible strategy
for teams and of course for individuals
as well
trade-offs are real and they should be
embraced and even celebrated because
they're the essence of what great
strategy are all about
one thing you can do immediately is to
ask the question what trade-off am i
going to make
when you're faced with two options of
what to do in this moment don't say i'm
just going to do both say which
trade-off am i going to make what do i
need to say no to
in order to say yes to this
number four is intent or more
particularly to create an essential
intent most teams that i have worked
with most companies and most individuals
have a challenge when it comes to
creating clarity about what they want in
the future most vision statements and
mission statements and value statements
are so ambiguous even though they're
meant to inspire they often leave people
none the wiser about what to actually
pursue and what not to pursue they are
therefore not fit for purpose but when i
coach individuals and ask them okay what
is essential to you to achieve over the
next two to three years if there's only
one thing that you could do what is it
i'm almost always
faced with a blank stare or a list of
many many different things
what would the power be if you could
identify a single essential intent that
could help you
to navigate everything else along your
journey
there is a structure that can be really
useful in helping you identify an
essential intent it's the following
verb
population outcome date it's a bit like
a mad libs exercise verb
what is it that you can uniquely
contribute what is it that you do better
perhaps than anyone else
population who are the most important
people in your life
who are the most important customers in
your business
outcome
what is the benefit to them what is the
priority benefit to them there may be
many benefits but what's the priority
benefit and then date to be able to turn
your intent into a specific metric add a
date by which you want to achieve it
as you start to whittle away at your
essential intent
be careful to stop wordsmithing and
start deciding when developing
statements of purpose whether it's for
your company your team or for yourself
there's a tendency i've noticed where
people start obsessing about trivial
stylistic details
should we use this word or that word
but this makes it all too easy to slip
into meaningless cliches and buzz words
that lead to vague meaningless
statements an essential intent doesn't
have to be elegantly crafted
it's the substance not the style that
counts so instead ask the more essential
question that will inform every future
decision you will ever make
if we could be truly excellent at one
thing
what would it be
an essential intent done right
is one decision
that makes a thousand
number five
is flow
or the genius of routine
for years before michael phelps won all
those goals at the 2008 beijing olympics
he followed the same routine every race
he arrived two hours early he stretched
and loosened up according to a precise
pattern
800 mixer 50 freestyle 600 kicking with
the kickboard 400 pulling a boy and more
after the warm-up he would dry off put
on his earphones and sit never lie down
on the massage table from that moment he
and his coach the rather remarkable bob
bowman wouldn't speak a word to each
other until the race was over at 45
minutes before the race he would put on
his race suit at 30 minutes he would get
into the warm-up pool and do 600 to 800
meters there with 10 minutes to go he'd
walk to the ready room he would find a
seat alone never next to anyone he liked
to keep the seats on both side of him
clear for his things goggles on one side
towel on the other
when his race was called he would walk
to the blocks
there he would do what he always did two
stretches first a straight leg stretch
and then with a bent knee
left leg first every time
then the right earbud would come out
when his name was called he would take
out the left earbud
he would step onto the block always from
the left he would dry the block every
time
then he would stand flap his arms in a
felcium way
phelps explains it's just a routine my
routine it's the routine i've gone
through my whole life and i'm not going
to change it now and that is that but
his coach bob bowman who designed this
physical routine with phelps said that's
not all he also gave phelps a routine
for what to think about as he went to
sleep and first thing when he woke up he
called it watching the videotape there's
no actual tape of course the tape was
just a visualization of the perfect race
in exquisite detail
and slow motion
so phelps could visualize every moment
from his starting position on top of the
blocks through each stroke until he
emerged from the pool victorious with
water dripping from his face
he didn't do the mental routine
occasionally he did it every day before
he went to bed and every day when he
woke up for years
when bob wanted to challenge him in
practices he would shout
put in the videotape and phelps would
push beyond his limits eventually the
mental routine was so ingrained the bob
barely had to whisper the phrase
get the videotape ready
before a race
phelps was always ready to hit play
when asked about the routine bob said if
you were to ask michael what's going on
in his head before the competition he
would say he's not really thinking about
anything he's just following the program
but that's not really right it's more
like his habits have taken over when the
race arrives he's more than halfway
through his plan and he's been
victorious in every step all the
stretches went like he had planned the
warm-up laps were just as he visualized
his headphones are playing exactly what
he expected the actual race is just
another step in a pattern that started
earlier that day and has been nothing
but victories winning is a natural
extension
all of us know that phelps won the
record eight gold medals at the beijing
olympics but i was always fascinated by
how he'd done it in a way that made it
look so effortless and of course
practice is part of it
but routine
is embedded in all of that practice
in making it appear to be as effortless
as it appeared
i talked to bob bowman just recently
and he talked me through his experience
in the final race of those eight gold
medals
after it was done and he himself said it
had surprised him at how effortless it
had actually been
when visiting beijing years after phelps
breathtaking accomplishment i couldn't
help but think how phelps and the other
olympians had all made their feet look
so effortless it's certainly a testament
to the genius of the right routine the
way of the non-essentialist is to think
that essentials only get done when they
are forced
that execution is a matter of raw effort
alone you labor to make it happen you
push through you even force it through
but the way of the essentialist is
subtly different
the essentialist designs a routine that
makes achieving what you have identified
as essential the default position my
suggestion to you is to tackle your
routines one by one it would be
unfortunate a little ironic even if you
become so taken with the genius of
routine that you're tempted to try to
overhaul lots of routines and all at the
same time what i've learned is that if
you start slow and small with routines
you can layer them on one after another
in order to utterly change the results
and the performance of your life
once we master routines
things become automatic and that's an
enormous victory
once you put the routines in place they
are gifts that keep on giving
let's go back to the questions i asked
at the beginning have you ever found
yourself stretched too thin have you
ever been busy but not productive do you
feel like your time is constantly
hijacked by other people's agenda the
way out
is the way of the essentialist i've
covered five specific things you can do
right now to become more essentialist
and therefore to be able to operate at a
higher point of contribution
if you have found this episode useful
please subscribe to the greg mcewen
podcast also my newsletter greg mcewan
dot com forward slash 1mw
read essentialism read effortless
because i didn't just write them i wrote
them for you
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin marketing solutions linkedin is
one of the most effective places for b2b
marketers to engage with decision makers
influencers and leaders linkedin's
platform is built to make b2b marketing
more effective for your business with
tools to help you develop better
relationships with your key customers
while building your brand it has the
trusted data and lead generation that
you need to be kpis drive roi and stand
out amongst the competition all the
things and with the marketing tools on
linkedin you can reach your precise
audience right down to their job title
company name location and much more to
make sure your ads are always being seen
by those who matter to you rethink your
b2b marketing with linkedin ads and get
a 100 credit on your next campaign go to
linkedin.com
tfs to claim your credit as in tim
ferriss show that's linkedin.com
tfs you can also find the link in this
episode's description
for a quickie and a change of pace what
follows is the wildly popular two-minute
good in all caps clip from jocko willink
jocko willink on twitter at jocko
willing that's j-o-c-k-o-w-i-l-l-i-n-k
is one of the scariest human beings i
have ever met he is one of the scariest
people imaginable he is a lean roughly
230 pounds and a brazilian jiu jitsu
black belt who used to tap out let's
call it 10 to 20 navy seals per workout
he's a legend in the special operations
world and his viral podcast interview
with me which you can find at tim.blog
jocko was the first long-form public
interview maybe the first public
interview he ever did you can find his
podcast which is massively popular jocko
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
and i was so impressed by this good clip
that a slightly edited text version of
it appears in one of my previous books
tools of titans please enjoy
one of my
direct subordinates one of my guys that
worked for me he would he would call me
up or pull me aside with some major
problems some issue that was going on
and he'd say awesome we got this and
that and the other thing and i'd look at
him and i'd say
good
and finally one day he was telling me
about some issue that he was having some
problem and
he said i already know what you're gonna
say
i said well what am i gonna say he said
you're gonna say good
he said that's what you always say when
something is wrong and going bad you
always just look at me and say good
and i said well yeah
when
things are going bad
there's going to be some good
that's going to come from it
didn't get the new high speed gear we
wanted
good
didn't get promoted
[Music]
good
more time to get better
oh mission got cancelled
good we can focus on another one didn't
get funded didn't get the job you wanted
got injured sprained my ankle got tapped
out good
got beat
unexpected problems
good
we have the opportunity
to figure out a solution
that's it
when things are going bad
don't get all bummed out don't get
startled don't get frustrated
[Music]
if you can say the word good
guess what
it means you're still alive
it means you're still breathing
and if you're still breathing
well now
you still got some fight left in you
so get up
[Music]
dust off
reload
recalibrate
re-engage
and go out on the attack
and now a clip from the tim ferriss show
this is a clip from my most recent
interview with brene brown many of you
know her brene you can find her on
twitter at brene brown is a research
professor at the university of houston
and a visiting professor in management
at the university of texas at austin
mccombs school of business she's the
author of six
count them six number one new york times
bestsellers and is the host of the
spotify original podcasts unlocking us
and dare to lead you can find my first
interview with brene at tim dot blog
slash brene
how do you answer that question if i
said tim
where's the line between
being our best selves or striving for
excellence
and
embracing who we are
funny you should ask because we're
recording this in january 2020 and i
thought a lot about this
on new year's eve and in the few days
after
the passing of the new year when i was
going through notes and photographs and
everything from the past year and i'm
actually still doing that review i mean
we're
well through the midpoint of january and
i'm still doing my last year review and
one of the conversations
with
my girlfriend with some of my best
friends was this topic exactly
and i can tell you where i landed
because i wanted to try to get the right
phrasing for me of the question
so i talked about the line right like
and there were a number of different
versions of the question one was how can
you be self-accepting
without
becoming complacent oh god that's right
that's it like that was one right that's
great that was one and then that's good
you know how can you conversely like how
can you be high achieving
without being self-flagellating or
self-abusing
and i thought about another good one i
thought about the line right as you
phrased it i thought about the line and
i realized that i had trouble answering
that question like where the line is
so the question that
i started to ask myself which was
informed by a book i've been reading for
the last month or so called already free
which
is written by a boulder-based
psychotherapist who also is a
buddhist contemplative
and he would be the first to say these
two do not mesh they actually contradict
each other in some ways but you can make
room for and use both
so
informed by this book which i was
reading during the passing of the new
year
i thought to myself
maybe the question is how can i make
room for both
striving
and self self acceptance and
so this might seem really clinical and
boring but i just schedule
blocks of time for both and
practices for both so for instance
there's a journal called the five minute
journal and part of that is
what i'm grateful for three bullets
what made today great three bullets and
those are generally small things
sometimes they're big things but i try
to include at least one small thing so
that i don't become
myopically fixated on the
extraordinary right right and uh because
i think one of the risks of
being heavily achievement focused is
that you only give yourself a pat on the
back when
you've done something that is the
equivalent of
a home run talk or
a massive project launch or setting a
world record of some type in your mind
and you can become really miserable that
way so in my
personal life driving an achievement
being in gear six is and has been
forever the default right and i think
that's a coping mechanism
for a lot of things that happened when i
was younger but nonetheless that is the
default
so the
self-acceptance is putting things in the
calendar as practices
that will ensure i take time for that
because my experience is that
if i don't put them in the calendar they
just get squeezed out by everything else
uh
how do you how do you think about it
well i'm changing in real time because i
love to make room for both but i think
the only place that i
have come to
around using my question about the line
where's the line between complain i love
that complacency
and
would you say complacency
self-acceptance complacency
self-acceptance and complacency
and for me i always think where's the
line
between
so i'll just take it to my to our
organization and my role as a leader in
that organization
we believe in excellence and beauty in
all things
and we are not jacking around like
like
if a font's wrong i will notice it
so where is the line between excellence
and beauty in all things and
perfectionism that is paralyzing no work
gets out so there's always you know
where's the line between my
perfectionism and my
being my best self
i the only thing i've come to so far
that has been the shift for me between
it's a midlife shift i think it's a
midlife shift for everyone and it's
taken me a good five years in midlife
i
will determine the line you will not
determine the line for me
so i know
i know that
for me
it doesn't matter what i'm achieving or
accomplishing if i'm not
eating in a way that makes sense for me
working out and sleeping
that
it doesn't matter so like for whether
you're saying boy you need to
you know lose 30 pounds or you're on the
side where you're like healthy at every
you know whatever it doesn't matter i
don't care what you think on either side
what i think is i know i need to work
out five days a week
i know
that i need to eat this way i know i
need to write down what i'm eating
i need because otherwise i'm like i can
be a stressed carb person so for me the
day i the day i reclaimed that line as
internally set not externally set was a
huge changer for me but i do think i
need to make room for both i i'm gonna
look into that like i
it is very buddhist it is it's not the
competition conflict thing yeah and and
what this author i'm blanking on his
name but we'll put in the show notes
what he uses as labels are on the on the
western psychotherapy side he talks
about the developmental view so you look
back at the the
outdated strategies that have become
patterns in your life that are no longer
applicable or are being overused and
then you take steps to sort of improve
or change your behaviors
and that would include your thought
patterns and then the
on the buddhist side
i would just say if if buddhist as a
word bothers you it's on the awareness
side
he would call it the fruitional view
which is being
effectively
becoming
and cultivating the ability to be okay
with whatever is and so another
aspect of this that i've been thinking
about a lot
is
there is there is uh there are different
types of self-acceptance
and i think this is really important and
it's only something i've thought very
closely about in the last handful of
years because i spent most of my life
hating myself at best tolerating myself
for moments but
there there's a lot of self-loathing
driving performance
and i for a long time viewed any type of
self-acceptance
as complacency just self-acceptance
equals complacency period yeah and you
need to be your own devil whipping
yourself in the back to try harder what
i've realized and this is informed by a
lot of reading of course is that there's
there's there is complacent
self-acceptance where you say everything
i'm doing is just fine i don't need to
change anything and i shouldn't change
anything yeah i want to oh yeah you need
to stop there for a second you can edit
it but i'm a pauser i need i'm a i have
to think there is such thing as what and
i can modify i can modify but i want you
to say what you just said what i said is
i do think there are multiple types of
self acceptance right and that that
that term self-acceptance could be used
to excuse complacency in the sense that
you could say i am
practicing self-acceptance which means
everything is great everything is as it
should be la la la i don't need to
change anything but then i'll just add
one more piece there's there is a
self-acceptance which says for instance
as an example i'm making this up like
right
right now i am
nervous and i'm frustrated and i'm angry
because a b and c is happening in my
life and we're doing this podcast and
i'm bald now and like in 2007 and oh my
god am i it's my head just a shiny cue
ball on camera right now blah blah and i
could accept all of those things as true
because they are those are my experience
and then for some of them i could
resolve to take steps to
improve upon those things right so
there's a situation i need to fix great
let me go fix it because that's making
me or
agitating me in some way so i think that
there are there's a there's a
self-acceptance which is a macro i don't
need to change anything and then there's
a self-acceptance which is really just
truthfully accepting whatever you're
experiencing at the moment as what is
happening as opposed to saying i don't
want to feel angry i don't feel angry
and like fighting and fighting and
fighting and tugging yourself in
multiple directions so that might sound
kind of esoteric but for me it's been
very profound
in that like you can be forgiving of
whatever you are experiencing in your
body in your psyche in the moment
while still
putting in place steps to improve
whatever it is you're hoping to improve
right i think it's possible to do both
i think it's i think it's possible to do
both too for sure i i do because i think
i live both and i do i go back to like
the union belief that the paradox is the
only
real thing that is
has enough tension to to capture human
experience so i think you can
have self-love and self-acceptance and
want to be better in other in ways i
think in fact i don't think you can
change without okay so here here here
are the pair here are the things i want
to unwind
i don't think you can truly
change for the better in a lasting
meaningful way unless it is driven by
self-acceptance i agree with that so i
think being the [ __ ] out of yourself
for performance which you know i work
with a lot of sports people now like it
works
and if all you have to do is pay someone
for one season or all you do is one game
or one whatever you're okay but lasting
meaningful change has to be driven by
self-acceptance yeah the other thing
that is just so shocking to me about
complacency and self-acceptance
is as i think back and i would really
have to go into the data but just
sitting here
i don't think
i have ever
come across a single person who i
not a single person that i can think of
who was complacent driven by
self-acceptance like
i don't think i don't know
i don't know that that is
not
an oxymoron
i got to tell you that like
self-aware
complacency doesn't work for me as a
construct self-aware no uh i i don't
know self-accepted complacency yeah i
don't know that i believe that yeah i
mean i'll i'll push i'll push a little
bit i would say you're going to get the
look on your face yeah i would say
and i think that i'm i'm struggling for
the right
terminology but i think we all know
people who are alcoholics
have various issues
and they are in denial of
having problems yes
let me stop you there yeah and say that
is neither self-awareness nor
self-acceptance definitely not
self-awareness but not self-acceptance
either well i would i we and maybe
there's a better word but i would just
say that there are people who are
delusional to the extent that they
either believe they don't have a problem
that they have or they have a problem
and refuse to accept it as a problem i
think for sure right so
so it and uh we can go a lot of
directions with this but i would i would
say that
uh
i think we can agree there are
complacent people
right there are complacent people and
among those complacent people i think
there are those
who
hate themselves there are those who sort
of love themselves and are
narcissistic and i know a number of
these
and
then there's a lot in between and i
think that you there are complacent uh
in some respects complacent narcissists
who
almost by definition being a narcissist
love themselves
so is that self-acceptance maybe yes
maybe no i would say that it is but it's
a disabling
self-acceptance whereas
to your point about lasting behavioral
change
i think that at least psychologically
if you are divorcing parts of yourself
if you hate parts of yourself aspects of
yourself that have been informed by your
history that
and i'm borrowing this phrase from
somewhere else but like what you resist
persists
right and that in that
you are going to carry that
unproductive and
in some ways self-defeating tension
within you even if someone is forcing
you to change your behavior or
incentivizing you to change your
external behavior right and so even if
technically you're changing a behavior
if you if you carry self-loathing even
partial self-loathing with you hating an
aspect of yourself or a certain emotion
within yourself
i view that as a loss i agree yeah so uh
this is this is getting out there a bit
but this this is this is the type of
stuff that sometimes i worry that i lose
that i've lost my audience could i make
a confession yeah because
for a long time i was thinking about
writing a blog post about this but for a
very long time if you look at all the
books that i've written it's like book
on entrepreneurship book on physical
performance book on cognitive
performance and learning four-hour chef
et cetera et cetera it's mostly
developmental it's about improving
performance in one or more areas and
now what i've spent more and more time
on like we're spending time on it right
now is the inner game
for sure and the importance of
developing a keen level of
self-awareness so that you can examine
the contents of your this is going to
get super wu for a second where it's
going to simply the contents of your
consciousness right like wherever you go
you're carrying your mind with you and
so to develop a familiarity with that i
think is the
the crux
skill that underlies everything else and
you and i both know plenty of achievers
who are miserable who are for sure high
performing
well-known people who are utterly
miserable and to me the question of why
is that how can that be the case
is
the question that i'm
extremely interested in these days and
um but i worry that having built an
audience
who is
largely not entirely kind of go go go
rah-rah-rah
win-win-win
there's nothing wrong with that but
people who are trying to develop skills
and
competitive advantages and so on that uh
that i may lose a large portion of those
people in shifting and talking about
more of these things
we'll see where it goes but that's
something that has occurred to me and i
think i'm willing to make that trade i
think i'm willing to to take that if
that's a cost of of doing business i
don't know i
so
a couple of things one
the go go go
audience that you've built
you this may scare them but i mean as
someone who works with elite athletes
and professional folks and ceos and
those things what i can tell you is
this is the hardest challenge you've
issued
like and it's not about the conceptual
complexity of what we're talking about
it's about
unlocking
performance is one thing unlocking
people
yeah way harder
way scarier and unlocking ourselves
and creating self-awareness
um to me it
to me you would be remiss not to go here
because
you know
i don't know i think
like something you said when you were
talking about we all know a lot of
narcissists and they love themselves but
that's actually not true
do you know that narcissism is the most
shame-based of all the personality
disorders
narcissism is not about self-love at all
it's about grandiosity
driven by high performance and
self-hatred
it's you know i define it as the
shame-based fear of being ordinary
and so you have to me you have this
audience that and i'm one of them i mean
like and i'm probably an outlier i guess
and you're it's like me being a rush fan
like
but there's always outliers
the audience is like 40 40 to 50 percent
female but i appreciate it yeah yeah it
is it's it's uh shifted a lot in the
last handful of years yeah but i think
you know
when i get invited in by a fortune 50
ceo and you know and here she says look
we need help we need help with the team
we need
they're not asking me to help with time
productivity right they're not helping
me to set up a scrum or agile process
for software development they're saying
you know we're at each other's throats
we hate each other it's a shame-based
finger-pointing like it's all about
self-awareness and changing those
behaviors and to me
you know
to me the hard thing about this
this area and your work
is
a lot of what i've learned from you that
has changed my life
has been
not only effectiveness based but
efficiency based
and so where you can lose people with
this conversation is this is not an
efficient process
yeah right do you mean
there's no i don't think there's a
four-hour
self-awareness
it's like i have no plans to write that
yeah but i mean but like but people
would love it if you could if you could
unlock that fast but to me
this is the capstone conversation for
you yeah do you mean like i do because
what's it all in for yeah
you know like
i'm fit i'm winning
i'm
smart
i'm successful
and i'm on my third marriage and i don't
speak to any of my children yeah like
which you see a lot right i mean i see
all the time
yeah
right because i'm gonna i'm gonna tell
you
not to dismiss the importance of that
work
that's easier yeah yeah it is easier it
is easier you know because
the thing about these conversations that
you and i end up having every time we
sit down or there's a second time but
both times we've sat down is
what what differentiates us as a social
species
is
the need to be seen and known and loved
and the need to see and know and love
others
and
no one rides for free like we all come
into this adulthood
with
hard stuff
and
what i would say
is true about complacency
and 95
of what i see
that people call pathology
is it's armor
yeah
it's not it's armor it's
how its behaviors and ways of thinking
that i've developed
to protect myself from being hurt
and now
another clip from the tim ferriss show
this is a clip from my most recent
interview with naval ravikant a very
close friend of mine
naval you can find him on twitter at
naval n-a-v-a-l is the co-founder and
chairman of angel list he is an angel
investor which is a huge understatement
he's invested in more than 100 companies
including many many mega successes to
name a few twitter uber notion open door
postmates and wish you can subscribe to
naval his podcast on wealth and
happiness on apple podcast spotify
overcast or wherever you find your fine
podcasts you can also find my first
interview with naval which was at the
time and probably still one of my most
popular episodes ever at tim.blog slash
naval
your pin tweet is a tweet storm so it's
a series of tweets the headline of which
is how to get rich and then in
parentheses without getting lucky it has
as we record this 44.8 000 retweets 110
plus thousand favorites
we're not gonna go through this whole
thing it's quite long but i'm curious to
know
what parts of it you think people are
paying too much attention to or
overemphasize and what parts of it do
you wish people would pay more attention
to because there are many different
pieces of advice in this thread
that tweet storm is a series of
principles that i kind of wrote for
myself in my head when i was 13 and i
was trying to figure out how to make
money and it kind of came with a
framework of how to be rich but not by
accident to do it in a way that i could
repeat it over and over and it would
leave very little up the chance
because i think there's kind of this
it's not completely mythology but
there's this belief that you know to
make money you either have to be born
rich or you have to be privileged or you
have to be in the right circles you have
to get lucky and i think that there are
still ways to accomplish the original
american dream which is you know make
money but do it in a deliberate
systematic way and when i say money i
mean wealth i don't mean like a law firm
where you make you know a couple hundred
bucks an hour but you're still tied to
the clock i mean like when you wake up
when you want you go to sleep when you
want you know you live where you want
and you have freedom so to me the
purpose of money is freedom
and for that you need to create wealth
and can you do it ethically can you do
it sustainably can you do it reliably
can you do it with people that you like
can you do it doing things that you
enjoy
and i think it's absolutely possible and
i'd like to think that i'm at least one
of many living proof points for that you
know warren buffett and charlie munger
are examples of others uh not that i'm
in their status of their league but you
know other people have done it so
that was the whole point of that
framework and the tweetstorm i just
wrote it down one day and it's funny
because obviously i have some experience
at twitter so i know how to craft things
but i think that was written back in the
day when the tweet limit was 140
characters too so it's harder but i just
woke up one night when i've been
thinking about it and i wrote out the
whole tweetstorm almost exactly like you
see it and there are lots and lots of
missing pieces like obviously that is
just like a very high level very zen
cone like or or haiku like or even
hallmark card like framework it's
missing a ton of details which i then
tried to extrapolate on in my podcast
series on the same topic
what do people over emphasize and what
are people missing
and actually novel let me pause and just
read a few of them this is from
may 31 2018 so a few examples and you
don't have to comment on these specific
examples but just for people who haven't
seen this i want to give them an idea so
the
second of
these various tweets in this sequence is
understand that ethical wealth creation
is possible if you secretly despise
wealth it will elude you
end of
that particular tweet
and then
there's another one you're not going to
get rich renting out your time you must
own equity a piece of a business to gain
your financial freedom that one right
there is the most important one which is
you basically
in modern life what happens is like the
person who is the best at doing
something in the world will get to do it
for the entire world through a
combination of leverage and distribution
accountability and specific knowledge
with all of which i talk about in the
tweet storm
if you're the best in the world of doing
something like if you're the best
teacher in the world at math you should
be teaching the entire world math if
you're the best podcast interviewer you
should be doing all the top interviews
and their returns will accrue to you
especially in this highly digital world
where we live in where the cost of
distributing something is very close to
zero
and so
what you kind of want to do is you want
to productize yourself into a business
and then you want to own that business
that is the way to make wealth um a
clear example is that tim ferriss
podcast the tim ferriss brand right
you're it's an eponymous brand your name
is on it you're leveraged through this
podcast and through the books that you
write uh and through the army of
followers that you have on the various
media platforms and you're taking on big
accountability and their specific
knowledge only you know how to be tim
ferriss the learning machine who can
then connect to other learners and
extract value out of them and share that
with the audience so that's an example
of you having productized yourself but
ultimately you own the tim ferriss
business now you can go lower levels
down from that you don't have to own the
entire business you could be an investor
in public equities or private stocks you
could be
a partner in a private business
you could be an employee a startup where
you have stock options but if you don't
own a piece of a business you're gonna
it's gonna be extremely hard to get
wealthy it'll be nearly impossible
almost not worth that route so i think
that is the most important foundational
tweet i think where people kind of all
kind of miss the plot the most though
is we have pain avoidance in life we
don't want to face things where it's
clear we've made bad decisions because
one good definition of suffering is that
that's the moment when you see things as
they clearly are and you kind of don't
like what you see like for example if
you if you and your spouse have been
fighting for a long time you know you've
kind of been sweeping under the rug and
you've sort of been suffering along but
you're sweeping on the wrong and then
you get divorced at that moment you can
no longer unsee all the damage that was
in the relationship and what all the
consequences are they're real
uh the same way if you haven't been
taking care of your health but then
suddenly you find out that you've just
fallen off a cliff and something
irreversibly bad has happened the moment
of suffering arrives and you're in pain
because you can no longer unsee this
thing you can no longer avoid it so i
think the same way
the unfortunate part is that a lot of
these principles are written for young
people because you can set yourself on a
certain trajectory in life earlier and
so for example if you went and you got a
you know a phd in a social science and
now i'm basically saying hey learn the
code
you're going to avoid that you're not
going to want to see that because you
have all this sunk cost in the degree
so i think a lot of people don't want to
pick up the new skills that are
necessary or they don't want to for
example physically move or they don't
want to disappoint the people in the
relationships that they already have to
make room for new relationships so
everybody wants to start where they are
nobody wants to go back down the
mountain to find the path going to the
top everybody wants to stay on the path
they're on maybe make a few tweaks and
get to the top or like charlie munger
jokes you know people always ask me like
how do i get to be rich like you except
quicker i don't want to be the old rich
guy i want to be the young rich guy
so i think these are the hard parts the
the the hard parts are not the learning
is the unlearning it's not the climbing
up the mountain it's the going back down
to the bottom of the mountain and
starting over it's the beginner's mind
that every great artist or every great
business person has which is you have to
be willing to start from scratch you
have to be willing to hit reset and go
back to zero because you have to realize
that what you already know and what
you're already doing is actually an
impediment to your full potential and
most people just don't want to
acknowledge that and i'm guilty of that
too that's just human nature i'm not i'm
not faulting anybody for it but it's
just human nature and if we look at
your specific case as it relates to
equity you mentioned owning part of a
business you also mentioned
in this conversation productizing
yourself so would you view
your success
in following that principle
predominantly in for instance the equity
that you own in a
company like angellist or is it the
identity and the brand meaning
associations that you've built as naval
the human or is it slash investor
therefore being sought after as an
investor or is it something else how
would you think of that principle
as applying yeah most in your own life
because you've created wealth not just
through say your equity and angelus but
also through many successful investments
and then i'm sure there are other ways
that we could
identify wealth as is coming from your
path that you know what i what i like
about my path is that i've made money
doing a lot of different little things
so i've made you know money consistently
in sort of small to medium-sized chunks
i haven't had like one gigantic payday
that set me up forever
although it depends on your standards
right i'm talking about by silicon
valley standards obviously for most
parts of the world i've had many of
those gigantic paydays but they've been
consistent and they've been varied
varied in the sense of that they're
completely different kinds of
investments and endeavors but consistent
in that i get one every couple of years
which would i just want to interject for
a second which would seem to suggest
that there is a there are principles
guiding your approaches or absolutely
right therefore yeah you're not relying
on winning the powerball lottery or that
equivalent no not at all no there's no
lottery here to win the lottery is for
losers lotteries are just attacks on
people who can't do math uh rich get
rich quick schemes are just other people
getting rich off of you there are no
shortcuts
so what i'm doing is i am taking my
specific knowledge which is my ability
to understand deeply technical concepts
and communicate them to the rest of the
world to be an interface between great
programmers and developers and designers
and the capital markets and consumers
and using that to put myself in a
position where then i can identify great
trends as they're emerging invest in
those companies or help start those
companies own equity in those things
help bring them to market help do the
strategy on how to navigate the worlds
of fundraising and exiting and
recruiting and company building and
cultures and technology development and
all that
and have a brand around it and i use
that to kind of make money and that is
just one of several ways you know i've
also done it by investing early on in
public markets and cryptocurrencies and
starting funds and all kinds of things
but i don't
it's funny i don't really follow my own
principles anymore like for example the
whole podcast thing and the whole
twitter thing even though i've got
reasonably good brands and followers and
those i'm not monetizing them at all i'm
not charging anybody for anything
because i'm not trying to make money
anymore to me that making money is like
you become the kind of person that makes
money
and you put yourself in long-term
situations where you're always going to
make money so i have the brand and i
have
deep relationships with a dozen people
who i know and i trust that i can do
business with the rest of my life and
they're very high integrity people
they're very capable people and just
makes it easy to do things so i've set
up that infrastructure now the money
just kind of makes itself as i go about
my life i don't want to have to work
hard i don't have to roll out of bed at
a certain time i don't have to answer to
somebody
so i optimized for independence and
freedom i could have made a lot more
money by raising a huge fund or joining
a big vc firm early on or being exec at
one of the massive companies in silicon
valley early on but i always optimize
for independence i'm lazy you know i
wake up at 7 8 9 10 a.m i go to sleep at
2 3
a.m you know i don't work a lot of days
some days i work morning tonight but
it's just based on whatever i'm curious
about i never want to have to answer to
a boss no one's ever going to tell me
what to do i don't want to order people
around i don't want to have someone
reporting to me and kind of asking me
all the time what to do
i want peer relationships i want to flow
i want to be able to do business while
walking you know in a forest talking on
a cell phone or sitting in a meeting or
in front of a computer or i want to be
on a beach if i don't feel like it the
ideal would be to make money with your
mind not with your time so if i can just
make one good decision a year and that
makes me all the money that i need for
that year then that's perfect and that's
the way it should be because we're
living in an age of infinite leverage
and your judgment just gets multiplied
through this massive force multiplier
through code capital community labor
what have you
so if you're smart and you kind of know
what you're doing you don't need to work
hard working hard is the last least
important thing you have to pay your
dues you have to put in all the
iterations 10 000 iterations not 10 000
hours to figure out what to do and how
to do it well but once you know you
don't have to put in the time anymore
it's your judgment and the judgment
comes from clear thinking the clear
thinking comes from having time to
reflect and to pursue your genuine
intellectual curiosity and you'll see
that a lot of the great investors for
example just sit around reading most of
the time or warren buffett famously
plays a lot of bridge
obviously not everyone can be just an
investor although that is becoming more
and more democratized and i've picked
something that suits my temperament and
particular capabilities but there's lots
and lots of ways to make money if you
apply your mind to it so i don't work to
make money i mean if i make so much
money that i'm donating hospital wings
and universities and all that stuff i
overshot you know i'm not trying to have
some influence on the world through
money and ironically i'm more influence
of the world through podcasts like this
and so you know making more money
doesn't change my life it doesn't change
the world as much as i could by doing
other things so there's not much
incentive for me to make money anymore
other than just practicing my craft
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim dot blog friday type that into your
browser tim dot blog
friday drop in your email and you'll get
the very next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement i've been asked this for
years the answer is invariably ag-1 by
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance so you can cover
your bases if you're traveling if you're
just busy you're not sure if your meals
or where they should be it covers your
bases i've recommended it
since the four hour body which was god
eons ago 2010 and i did not get paid to
do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods source
ingredients you'll be hard-pressed to
find a more nutrient-dense formula on
the market it has a multivitamin
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes and
adaptogens
you get the idea it is very very
comprehensive and i do my best of course
to focus on nutrient-dense proper meals
but sometimes you're busy sometimes
you're traveling sometimes you just want
to make sure
that you're getting what you need ag-1
makes it easy to get a lot of nutrition
when whole foods aren't readily
available it's also nsf certified for
sport making it safe for competitive
athletes as what's on the label is in
the powder it's the ultimate all-in-one
nutritional supplement bundle in one
easy scoop right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix sleep and
their mattresses which i've been using
since 2017 i have two of them upstairs
from where i'm sitting at this moment
helix has gone beyond the bedroom and
started making sofas they've launched a
company called all form
a-l-l-f-o-r-m and they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores so i'm
sitting in my living room right now and
it's entirely all formed furniture i've
got two chairs i've got an ottoman and i
have an l sectional couch and i'll come
back to that you can pick your fabric
they're all spill stain and scratch
resistant the sofa color the color of
the legs the size the shape to make sure
it's perfect for you and your home also
all form arrives in just three to seven
days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular and easy these things fit
together kind of like lego pieces
they've got arm chairs love seats all
the way up to an 8c sectional so there's
something for everyone you can also
start small and kind of build on top of
it if you want to get a smaller couch
and then build out on it which is
actually in a way what i did because i
can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman in a matter of about 60 seconds
it's pretty rad so i mentioned i have
all these different things in this room
i use the natural leg finish which is
their lightest color and i dig it and
i've been using these things hours and
hours and hours every single day so
i am using what i am sharing with you
guys and if getting a sofa without
trying it in store sounds risky you
don't need to worry all form sofas are
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it that's
more than three months and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a full refund your sofa frame
also has a forever warranty that's
literally forever so check it out take a
look they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked much better
than i could have imagined and i'm very
very happy so to find your perfect sofa
check out allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m.com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout that's allforum.com
tim and use code tim at checkout
[Applause]